Is it 'cause of the...
This is my mom, hold on.
Hi, baby!
(DeAngelo laughs)
I'm trying to work right now,
you over there calling my phone.
This is DeAngelo, you can say hi.
Hi, DeAngelo!
And don't be holding up traffic,
'cause you got cars behind you.
All right.
(DeAngelo laughs)
Did you record that?
Aw, welcome back, that's the viral video
of Sandi and Myles Harris, an amazing mother and son duo.
And it was seen more than 10 million times.
That's what they call going viral.
Myles is a reporter at our affiliate ABC 6
in Columbus, Ohio.
And when they visited us here in the studio,
they were right here.
That's right, there we all are.
Cute.
(audience applauds)
We turned the questions on them
and we found out that Sandi,
his mom has dreams of being a reporter too.
Yes, and they're reporting
on their very first story together
by introducing us to an incredible Drew Gooder named Jenna.
She's the President of Fairy Goodmothers,
an nonprofit that gives out free prom dresses
to girls in the community.
Yes!
So let's make a couple dreams go true right now.
We're gonna go live to them now at the ABC 6 studios.
Hi, guys, hi.
Hi!
Hi.
Hi, how are you?
How does it feel to be reporting together?
Fantastic.
(Ross laughs)
Dream come true.
I get to be the teacher today, I guess, right?
Mm, here we go.
(Drew laughs)
Yeah, here we go, exactly.
And what a great story too.
We get to meet Jenna.
Hi, Jenna.
Hi, Jenna!
Hi.
Now, Jenna, it's so great to meet you
and we know that you volunteered-
I'm so excited.
Yes, well, and you've been a volunteer in your community
since middle school.
Why has giving back been so important to you for so long?
Well, I felt like at that moment in time,
it's a big deal in middle school
to realize that there are other people out there.
You actually start to realize the world
is bigger than yourself.
And when I realized that,
I realized how important little moments were to people,
little interactions with somebody.
You don't really know what kind of interaction
you're gonna have,
but you can leave it a little bit better than you started.
And so once I realized that,
I thought, I'll start to volunteer.
I learned a lot about a lot of different causes,
but it was really only when I got to Fairy Goodmothers
that I realized this is the thing that I wanna do
for a little bit longer.
Now, Jenna, you've actually been
with Fairy Goodmothers since 2014.
So tell us really how this whole organization
really works out.
Yeah, so it gives away prom dresses to young people
who can't afford them.
And it's not necessarily just about a dress.
It's really about making sure the confidence and self-esteem
that people can have is coming out in one particular moment.
Wow, that's so cool.
(audience applauds)
So Jenna, tell me, what's been the most rewarding thing
being part of this program?
I think it's those moments that I was talking about,
because we would have little times
when somebody would interact, you would see somebody
when they found their perfect dress, stand up straight
or interact more with somebody.
They would talk differently.
And I remember one time when there was a girl
who came to the shop and she got to the checkout area,
and she was so serious and she was very emotional,
and she said, "This is the very first day
I've ever felt beautiful."
And to us that meant so much,
but one of our board members said,
"No, this is the first day that you've ever seen it."
And it's moments like that,
somebody remembers that for a really long time.
Oh, yeah, touches your heart.
Right.
Yeah.
Well, we wanted to help you out today.
And our way of helping out was reaching out
to David's Bridal and they are donating $10,000
to Fairy Goodmothers.
Oh my god.
That's fantastic, yes.
And not only that,
they are donating 300 prom dresses to you
and that is a gift that's worth $80,000.
Wow!
(audience cheering)
(audience applauding)
That sounds amazing.
I love that, thank you so much.
Well, thank you for building it
and thank you, Sandi and Myles,
for doing this most important story with us.
And Jenna, I hope this helps, I know it's gonna work.
It does, thank you so much.
And David's Bridal, thank you.
Thank you so much.
Love this.
And to learn more about the Fairy Goodmothers,
this beautiful organization,
please go to our website at thedrewbarrymoreshow.com.
Myles and Sandi, I love you guys so much.
Great job!
We love you too.
(audience cheers)
(audience applauds)
May this be the first of so many stories we do together.
(upbeat bright music)